[Music]
today we cancel
john lewis um not the late congressman
but the uk company which provides home
insurance among other things the
company's been making some headlines
mostly positive headlines over in
inclusive
and progressive new advertisement which
features as so many ads do these days
a young boy cross-dressing now the ad
title we just play the ad here while i'm
talking um so you could see the the ad
is titled let life happen and it opens
with the boy in what appears to be his
sister's room
kind of dolled up in uh in girl clothes
with makeup smeared all over his face
and he's got jewelry on and he's got
he's got high heels
and the room is completely trashed and
torn apart
and then an area is there
and then the boy begins dancing through
the house and he's at one point he's
smearing paint on the walls kicking over
lamps
tearing books off the shelves
uh he knocks over his sister's paints
and he spills them on the carpet
towards the end he throws glitter all
over the living room he starts dancing
on top of the table
and then you see at one point his mother
is looking on with a blank expression
and then the ad ends with the words let
life happen home insurance
is that that's the ad
now before we even get to the issue of
the boy in the dress
i think there are a number of basic
concept problems with this ad
the first is that no insurance company
on earth i can tell you this right now
including john lewis i'm quite sure
will cover damage to your home which has
been caused intentionally by your bratty
child while you sat there and watched
anyone who's ever dealt with home
insurance companies knows that home
insurance in general is great until you
actually have to use it okay the
insurance companies would prefer that
you just pay them each month and never
actually use the product you've been
paying for if you do dare to file a
claim they're almost offended when you
when you call them up and say i gotta
file a claim what you what do you mean
you gotta file a claim
they'll do everything in their power to
ensure that your claim isn't covered by
the policy you paid for
there's almost always some fine print
technicality like you call and say that
you have a burst pipe and they'll say uh
well when when did the pipe burst and
you'll say it happen on tuesday morning
and they'll say oh well oh unfortunately
if the pipe burst on tuesday between 6
15 a.m and 8 17 a.m we can't cover it
that wasn't your policy it's uh you know
unfortunately we just we just can't
so my point is that
they definitely aren't covering the
damage done by your out-of-control son
during his impromptu drag performance
even if they say they will they won't
but maybe that's neither here nor there
the real point is that the marketing
agency that made this ad went out and
hired a young boy dressed them up in
makeup and heels and told him to dance
around the house while they film him
why
well because the people behind this ad
are a bunch of creepy disgusting freaks
and like all the other creepy disgusting
freaks who run our culture they really
want your child to be gender fluid they
especially want this for young boys i
mean when you see this kind of thing in
mainstream advertisements advertisements
for normal everyday products like home
insurance
then you see all the books in the
children's section of barnes noble that
feature boys dressing like girls and you
see the drag queen story hours and all
the rest of it it becomes quite clear
that the promotion of gender ideology
has become the priority number one for
our cultural overlords
it's the most important thing to them
they desperately want your kids to buy
in especially your sons
so it's it's uh
interesting to note that
the majority of kids who fall into the
trap and start identifying as gender
fluid or trans are girls
this kind of thing is the most common
among adolescent girls these days and
yet it would seem
that most of the effort is put into
inducting boys into the cult
why is that well i think girls reach a
certain age right around puberty
when they're especially susceptible to
the to the um
to the gender cult
you know they go through a period of
feeling uncomfortable in their own
bodies not at home in their bodies uh
boys may have something like that as
well but it's not nearly as pronounced
the gender cult gives girls a framework
for understanding these natural and
fleeting feelings
the cultists sees on this normal phase
of girlhood and use it as a wedge
to pry girls away from their true and
natural identities with boys it would
seem the job is harder
boys have their own bewildering
experiences in puberty but it's not the
same
and the feelings of physical alienation
within your own body are again not
nearly as powerful in boys as they are
in girls which means that if the gender
cultists want to get to boys they need
to start younger
and they need to be more aggressive
they need to try harder
and that's why it's almost always boys
being targeted by these kinds of things
even as girls make up the majority of
the kids who ultimately fall victim to
it
but the funny thing about this ad
is that it actually makes the opposite
point from the one that it's trying to
make
because the boy in the ad
is immature
out of control
childish destructive
when left to his own devices when his
mother just sits there and lets him do
what he wants offering no guidance or
correction at all
he makes himself and the home into a
disaster zone
the boy can't be given that kind of free
reign he needs instruction he needs
careful parental oversight
that's not what the ad is trying to
demonstrate but that's what it did
demonstrate
and that's also why you can't let kids
choose their own gender because they
lack the maturity and discernment and
long-term decision-making ability to to
determine that for themselves
of course nobody can determine it for
themselves because biology determines it
but children especially can't be given
that kind of power
and so
the ad
would seem to illustrate that for us
quite profoundly and also quite
unintentionally
when you as a parent just sit there
drinking your coffee
letting your kid live their life
without giving any guidance
you know
letting them alone in the dark to fumble
their way through
without grabbing the flashlight yourself
and saying no child this this is the way
to go
when you do that this is what what you
end up with
you end up with a boy wearing drag
tearing your house apart
so
for that reason
although they ultimately made the
correct point unintentionally we still
have to say that john lewis home
insurance
and really maybe all home insurance in
the end
is uh cancelled hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated